- And I was very, very, very
sure that what we were doing
was extremely important.
We don't need a lot of grandstanders
and people that want
the spotlight on them.
I was willing to take
a chance because losing
wasn't the worst thing in
the world that could happen.
Nobody can do things by
themselves at any scale.
For the first time in history
you were able to see inventory
in motion or at rest.
The important thing is to
think beyond your local economy
to create higher margins
and increase growth
for your business.
All of a sudden you turn the kaleidoscope
and there you see something
that nobody saw before.
Find yourself something you're good at
and do it to perfection.
What's the purple promise?
And they'll say very
simply I think one thing.
I will make every FedEx
experience outstanding.
- He's the founder, chairman,
president, and CEO of FedEx.
In 2014, Fortune magazine ranked him
number 26 on the world's
50 greatest leaders.
He has an estimated net
worth of 3.6 billion dollars.
He's Fred Smith, and here is my take
on his top ten rules for success.
(wind howling)
(basketball bouncing)
- The reason I never left confidence
is because I never believed
that the consequences of losing
were as bad as some other
people might have thought.
You know, oh my goodness,
I've lost my money
or what have you, I just wasn't
motivated along those lines
and I was very, very, very sure
that what we were doing
was extremely important
and was destined to be successful.
So that's the definition, I think,
of an insane person or a zealot. (laughs)
And most entrepreneurs,
I think you would find,
have that sort of green wire laid in there
just a little bit crosswise
and they begin to get
focused on something and
they believe in the idea
or themselves far beyond
what they probably should.
We don't need a lot of grandstanders
and people that want
the spotlight on them.
You know, all the way back to Sun Tzu,
who made the famous quote that
if you're a good leader,
the ultimate test of that
is that the people will
accomplish great things
and they'll think you had
nothing to do with it.
So I think they have to be self-effacing,
I think they have to have an
understanding of the mission.
Whether it's football, or
in the military, or FedEx
or what have you they
got to have that DNA.
They've got to understand
those little tiny details
and be able to synthesize them together,
particularly at their organizations
and that's a very important thing.
Here's an inspiring story
from a recent edition
of the New York Times, for example.
It was about a Michigan
company called Bandals
that introduced a new product.
Women's sandals with
interchangeable decorative tops.
And they introduced these products
right after the economic
crisis hit in the fall of 2008.
Pretty brave thing to start
a business in that time
under any circumstances.
When the five-employee company was pounded
with manufacturing and
material cost increases
of up to 30%, and
remember the price of fuel
in the summer of 2008 went
to 147 dollars a barrel.
The owner, Tom Sesti, decided that Bandals
needed to sell his way out of the problem
and he made another
daring move in the midst
of that economic crisis,
and as it turns out
it was a very smart move, indeed.
Now, in the Chinese language,
the symbol for crisis and
opportunity are the same
and this gave Mr. Sesti
the wake-up call he needed.
He realized that because
Bandals sell best in warm months
expanding into overseas markets
with the year-round nice weather,
or with seasons that ran
opposite to those here
in the United States would be the way
to dig his business out of a hole.
After he did his homework and realized
it would cost much less than he expected,
he began selling Bandals in 15 countries.
By 2011 the company's revenue
had increased a whopping 250%
and his profits had tripled.
I think that's a great story
about a small business person
having the vision to see how his product
can appeal to global markets,
and how the technology
and supply chain advancements
we have today make it easier
and more cost-effective to
branch into those markets.
In retrospect, it was ridiculous to try
to put this system together,
which required so much up front money
and required changing a lot
of government regulations,
but I didn't know that at the time.
And I think probably my
experience in the service
where the currency of the
exchange in FedEx was just money.
You know, it wasn't people's
arms and legs or lives,
and so my perspective on
it was perhaps a bit more,
I don't know how you would say it.
I was willing to take a chance
because losing wasn't
the worst thing the world
that could happen to you, I
had seen that very clearly.
Nobody can do things by
themselves at any scale
and if you read about Marshall,
Marshall was extraordinarily
able to deal with difficult personalities
and to synthesize them into a team.
Admiral King, who was the
Chief of Naval Operations
at the time was a very prickly fellow.
He had a very tough personality
and he was found to be
intractable on many, many things,
but Marshall could deal with him
and he did it in many different ways,
many times being self-effacing
by walking over to King's
office and so forth.
Now, he ended up being in charge
of the whole shooting match
and Roosevelt's architect of the war,
but in the early stages, he had
to build that team synthesis
to get things done, and
he was a master at it.
We handle millions and
millions of pieces every day
and one of the things we did years ago,
which was very important,
is we figured out
our customers wanted the information
about where every one
of 'em was every day,
which was impossible at the time,
but we had an internal entrepreneur
that figured out how to do it.
He revolutionized all kinds of things.
It's a great story, I think it's in
the National Academy of Sciences
about how the FedEx people did it.
And the reason it was so important,
for the first time in history
you were able to see inventory
in motion or at rest.
Now, a warehouse doesn't add any value.
It's just a place to put
something so you know you got it.
Well, once we invented the
tracking of things in motion
you could keep track of inventory
whether it was moving
in a 500 mile an hour
or 550 triple seven,
or in a 50 mile an hour
FedEx over the road truck,
and it allowed people
to have fantastic productivity.
It's what allowed, along
with government deregulation
of transportation, things like Wal-Mart,
which is really a logistics
system, not just a retailer.
With the help of the internet,
and global logistics like we provide,
more small business have become part of
the global supply chain than
at any other time in history.
52% of all small businesses are home-based
and I think it's fair to say that people
are selling goods to the national
and international markets
that they could have only
sold locally 20 years ago
in many, many cases.
Now, whether you're expanding
nationally or internationally
the important thing is to
thing beyond your local economy
to create higher margins
and increase growth for your business.
I think some people just see
things that others don't.
There was a great professor
at your alma mater,
I hate to say it, Rosabeth Moss Kanter
and Professor Kanter used to describe it
as kaleidoscope thinking,
that you look at something
and it's a pattern and then
you turn the kaleidoscope
and it's another pattern
and it's meaningless
and all of a sudden you
turn the kaleidoscope
and there you see something
that nobody saw before.
I mean, clearly lots of
people fit into that category.
Steve Jobs, you see it with the products
that he's come out with and
Bill Gates and so forth.
I just think that General
Marshall in his field
was able to synthesize all of those things
that he learned in France
and the experiences
that he had in the army to
understand the great crisis
that was ahead and to
prepare for it uniquely.
And for those of you who don't know it,
he ran the army school at Fort Benning
and I think at Leavenworth, too
and he compiled a list of officers
that he felt in time of emergency
would be the ones that he should promote
if he were put in that position.
And he was put in that position
and he did promote them
with fantastic success over the heads
of many, many other
officers who were seniors
to the ones that had impressed him.
So he was able to see that
however it came about.
I thought many times about
the advice I might give
a graduating class, and I
can find no better quote
than one that was given some 200 years ago
by a Polish general Tadeusz Kosciuszko
who had come to the United States
to help Washington along with Lafayette
win our independence.
He was an engineer, fortified West Point
and was a major contributor to
the success of American arms.
He said shortly after the
war to a group of students
such as yourself, "Set yourself
to work with reflection
"and intelligence either
at your prescribed duty,
"carry it out in the
most scrupulous manner,
"or perfect yourself in some science
"in which you should have true mastery."
Perhaps in a shortened version,
General Colin Powell summed it up,
"Find yourself something you're good at
"and do it to perfection."
Something you enjoy, and if you do that,
I can promise you, as I have
over the past 30-some odd years
you won't feel that you've gone
to work a day in your life.
FedEx over its entire existence, David,
has gotten better and better
and better at what we do
and we've been able to do
that for three reasons.
One, the use of technology,
'cause just imagine
if we were handling all
those people of things a day,
and we couldn't keep track of them.
I mean, things would be going
to Mars, for goodness sake.
Secondly, we have availed ourselves
of the most advanced scientific
quality management systems
pioneered by Japanese industry
and led by Professor Deming
and Professor Juran 25, 30 years ago.
And third, we have a
culture which is represented
by very a very simple phrase.
We call it our purple promise.
Purple is the common color
for all of the FedEx branding.
We're a little like Coke,
you know, red's Coke Classic,
and silver is Diet Coke and Gold is,
I don't know what it is, but
it doesn't have much in it.
(audience laughing)
I drink it, but.
So, purple and orange is our
original express company,
purple and platinum is corporate,
purple and green is our
ground parcel company,
purple and blue, FedEx Office,
and purple and crimson is FedEx Freight.
So we have a very simple
phrase that every member
of the FedEx team knows
and I hope if you walk up
to somebody you ask them,
what's the purple promise?
And they'll say very
simply, I think one thing,
I will make every FedEx
experience outstanding.
So you don't need 18 manuals
and one thing or another.
You give them the best technology
and try to support 'em, and
the best management tools
and our team will deliver it.
So we've gotten better
and better every year
so we don't lose many of anyone's packages
most, including mine.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
girohead asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which of Fred Smith
top ten rules had the
deepest impact on you.
Leave it in the comments and
I will join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for
watching, continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
(wind blowing)
(basketball bouncing)